today on the matt wall show canada
criminalized christianity last week and
nobody seems to have noticed how did
that happen and are we on the same path
in this country also michael phelps
speaks out about the trans athlete issue
uh sort of stephen a smith returns to
the air to tell about his near-death
experience with kovid but he seems to
have learned the wrong lessons from the
ordeal and whoopi goldberg says that the
gop is going to try to remove voting
rights from women i have to admit that
the ladies of the view do make a
compelling argument for that policy
change and don lemon on cnn condemns the
quote idiots who do their own research
and our daily cancellation will deal
with the sports analyst who tried to
prove his anti-racist credentials by
bragging about his mlk memorabilia it
didn't go well as you might expect we'll
talk about all that and more today on
the matt walsh show
[Applause]
[Music]
you know i don't know a lot about
investment but one thing i do know is
you don't want to have all your eggs in
one basket you have to diversify your
investments and right now inflation is
at 40 years high 40-year highs and it's
here to stay because here's the
government's dirty little secret
not a very well kept secret is that they
want it that way think about this right
now inflation rates are higher than the
interest on treasury bonds so with every
day that passes the government owes less
on its mountain of debt imagine if your
mortgage had a negative interest rate
would you be in any hurry to pay it off
probably not so your pain is their gain
that's what it means protect your
savings now hedge against inflation with
gold from birch gold because the
government is sabotaging the value of
the us dollar birch gold will help you
convert an eligible ira or 401k into an
ira backed by real gold
and what do you get from that you get
not only a great investment but peace of
mind as well with thousands of satisfied
customers and an a plus rating with a
better business bureau you can trust
birch gold to protect your savings text
walsh to 98 98 98 to get a free info kit
on holding gold in a tax sheltered
account then call birch and protect your
hard earned savings again text walsh to
98 9898 to get your free info kit now
one of the most depressing realities of
my life over the last few years is that
as i've traveled around the country
speaking at college campuses the most
aggressive and hostile receptions i've
received by far
have been at the allegedly christian
institutions especially the catholic
ones in fact i have not encountered mass
protests against my talks except at
christian universities this is certainly
not the worst aspect of the fall of
christian education in the united states
but it is a revealing symptom
of the problem here's another as
reported by the daily wire it says
depaul university the largest catholic
college in the united states apparently
jumped at the opportunity to provide
students with at least eight different
genders to choose from unofficial
college documents and other student life
forms despite the fact that it likely
goes against catholic teaching on god's
creation of man and woman
the change comes as depaul's student
government association recently stated
that quote misgendering somebody is a
quote act of violence
the college fix recently flagged the
depaul student portal known as campus
connect a website used for keeping
information on and for students faculty
and staff for communication other
purposes
now allows students to choose either
male female intersex non-binary
transgender male transgender female cis
gender unspecified and i do not wish to
self-identify
the announcement was made on january 4th
and michael wright assistant vice
president depaul's registrar office said
the college wanted to promote ways for
students to express their identity if
they choose to do so
now it's no surprise that depaul has
gone this direction as the college fix
reported back in june according to daily
wire quote the catholic university's
lgbtqi plus resource center coordinator
in the office of multicultural student
success hold on a second the lgbtqi plus
resource center coordinator in the
office of the multicultural student
success
center
has this to say his name is michael
reilly he stated that calling somebody
by the gender or pronoun they were born
with when they've demanded others do not
do so is quote incredibly harmful quote
simply put misgendering folks is harmful
because it allows for trans and gender
expansive folks to be seen as jokes or
as less of a person it can make the
person feel like they are not important
enough to remember which is incredibly
harmful
reilly stated furthermore incorrectly
assuming someone's pronouns also assume
someone's gender which can lead to other
marginalized and harmful behavior he
added
he or she i don't know
um
the first problem of course is that they
created an lgbtqi
plus resource center and multicultural
center to begin with the rest flows
logically and inevitably from that
starting point
now de paul is of course just the latest
alleged christian institution to fully
endorse the left sexual ideology most
christian universities have gone down
this path
great many churches have as well i drove
by a church just yesterday here in
nashville with a with a giant rainbow
flag and blm logo hanging outside
now
a gay pride flag on a church
was unthinkable
as recently as a decade ago
you would have had to wander into the
most radical parts of san francisco or
you know portland or seattle or
something to see something like that
now it's totally commonplace everywhere
in the country red and blue states alike
you know canada essentially criminalized
christianity last week
as you heard about on this show
you didn't hear about it many other
places but we talked about it when their
dystopian
conversion therapy bill went into effect
threatening pastors with half a decade
in prison if they preach about christian
sexual ethics from the pulpit
it was
and is
the complete collapse of religious
liberty in the country
i mean religious liberty is gone doesn't
exist anymore in canada
and yet
this um situation was hardly noticed
largely because almost every pastor in
canada had long since abandoned
christian moral teachings especially as
it pertains to sex anyway
i mean they weren't talking about it in
the first place
a few brave holdouts have spoken out
since then
but there aren't nearly enough to make a
difference
the canadian government they would never
try to criminalize christianity if the
faith was vibrant and alive in the
country
a weak little worm like justin trudeau
he's not up for that fight
instead they wait
until it's almost entirely dead
and then they come in with the kill shot
we're headed in the same direction the
united states as always we're on the
same cultural track and train as canada
and europe but just a few cars behind
a lion will go for the slowest and
sickest antelope in the herd the
anti-christian tyrants in the west have
been themselves stalking in the grass
waiting until the church has hobbled
enough to strike
canada got to that point
and now religious liberty is gone
christian teaching is illegal in canada
right now
just up north from us
we're almost there as well
when we lose the will to resist even the
most radical depraved and sadistic
elements of left-wing orthodoxy
you know that the situation is terminal
now it shouldn't need to be explained
but i will anyway
a christian cannot countenance
any aspect of the left's gender ideology
without forfeiting his faith in the
process
every church or university that has
shown any tolerance for any part of this
doctrine has given up its faith
it is now apostate
because either god creates us and gives
us our identity male or female we are
created as the bible says in the very
first chapter
or
we create ourselves and determine our
own identities
it's one or the other
okay and if you choose the latter
then you have chosen a religious
doctrine but it is not a christian
doctrine
either god can make a mistake
and accidentally put a female soul into
a male body some sort of screw-up on the
cosmic assembly line
making him fallible error-prone and
frankly stupid
creating messes that we have to clean up
with with drugs and surgery or
god is all-knowing and all-powerful and
his wisdom exceeds our own by an
infinite margin
which means that even if you don't like
your own identity your biological
identity it's still right it's the right
identity
and it's you who are looking at it the
wrong way not god
those are the two options if you choose
the former
then you have chosen a religious
doctrine but it is not a christian
doctrine
and you are not a christian
so when i talk about the the gender
issue on this show i usually engage with
it from a from a rational logical
scientific standpoint
because you don't need to be a christian
to understand that men are not women any
more than you need to be a christian to
understand that two plus two two plus
two doesn't equal five
but it's still the case that this
ideology is fundamentally incompatible
with the christian faith
not just incompatible but in competition
with it
gender ideology militates against
christian teaching it was designed to do
just that
that's the point of it largely
it becomes a poison in the church's
bloodstream
and in america the church has been
choosing to take this poison
poisoning itself
until one day as in canada
it won't be a choice anymore
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
so we'll begin uh with
this michael phelps was on um i think it
was nbc
uh cnn doesn't matter they're all the
same and he was asked about the trans
sports issue especially when it pertains
to swimming cnn okay ask about uh you
know leah thomas and what's going on at
the university of pennsylvania and the
swimming and everything and it it makes
sense to talk to michael phelps uh about
this
and i first became aware of this
interview in this segment
because i saw conservatives on social
media some of them kind of celebrating
michael phelps's answer and saying oh he
he took a stand and he's on our side and
that would be fantastic if that was true
michael phelps that these are the kinds
of voices we need speaking out
but then i i went and i watched
this segment of the interview where he
allegedly took a stand and
um expressed his his uh
you know
he he he sided with with rationality and
all of that
i watched it and uh i don't know i i'm
not sure i quite see it but let's
let's watch
there as as you know a certain amount of
controversy around the university of
pennsylvania college college swimmer by
the name of leah thomas and there are
some people who are questioning her
uh i'm not sure what the right word is
her right to swim on a woman's team
she's transgender
what do you make of that she's obviously
doing exceptionally well she also has
been taking testosterone suppressants um
but nonetheless does much better
according to the records than her female
contestants
what do you make of this particular
situation i mean look like i i i'll say
you know i i can talk from a standpoint
of of doping um you know i i don't think
i've competed in a clean field in my
entire career
um so you know i i think this leads back
to the organizing committees again um
because it has to be a level playing
field i think that's something that that
we all need
um because it's it like that's what
sports are uh and for me um i i don't
know where this is going to go i don't
know um what's going to happen um i
believe that
we all should feel comfortable with who
we are in our own skin
um but i think sport should all be
played at an even playing field i don't
know what that looks like in the future
um but it's it's it's
it's hard
it it it's a really i i honestly
i i don't know it's complicated
it's very complicated and and
um you know this is this is my sport
this has been my sport my whole entire
career um and and i honestly the one
thing i would love is everybody to be
able to compete on an even playing field
that's all i can say
what a skulking little
jellyfish
he is which is which is appropriate
because he is a swimmer
but uh not a you know an invertebrate
swimmer is michael phelps the one reason
why this is being celebrated and
conservatives are giving him props for
saying this is that he said well we need
to be on a level playing field
but he he stops way short of actually
condemning the insane practice of
allowing men to compete against women
stops very short of that
so no this is not him taking a stand
this is him
avoiding it now he he indicates
that he knows that it's wrong
that's what the level playing field
thing is about
but he's too afraid to simply come out
and say well obviously men should
compete against women this is insane he
knows that but he's too afraid to say it
this is uh no this is not him taking the
right position this is not him being on
our side
this is him being an absolute gutless
despicable coward
even though he he risks almost nothing
i mean all the endorsement deals and
everything he's got whatever he's got
millions and millions of dollars he'll
be fine
he can do whatever he wants with the
rest of his life
what does he risk
in simply standing up
and saying what we all know is true
it'd be an awkward interview
on cnn and maybe some of his leftist
friends will look at him funny but
that's that's it
we need people like this
who are in the mainstream
if we're talking about sports that we
need athletes specifically
to speak out in the and almost all of
them refuse to do it
cowardice
one of one of the real epidemics we face
in this country is just a
an enormous amount of cowardice
he says it's complicated it's not
complicated there's nothing complicated
at all about this and and he knows that
well you know it's very very complicated
we've got the way to nope not at all
are you a man well you belong with the
men that's it
really as simple as that there's there's
nothing complex about this issue
the fact that a minority of people
would get their feelings hurt
if they were not allowed to compete
against women that does not make this
complicated
at all
and again he knows that
almost everyone in the country knows
that
almost everyone knows
that this is crazy
but very few are willing to say it
and this is also not about and we cannot
emphasize this enough
when we talk about this issue with
women's sports
um the primary concern here
is not
fairness
it's not protecting women's sports for
the sake of protecting women's sports
that's not the primary concern that's
not the fundamental concern
and that's not what makes this wrong
primarily
the primary concern as always is just is
truth it's is is reality
so why is it wrong to have leah
quote-unquote thomas competing against
women
yeah it's unfair to the women it
destroys women's sports that that's a
problem
but the main reason that uh we should be
against it is that it's it's it's not
true he's he's not a woman it's it is
not true
but the more that we this is what makes
me really uncomfortable because even
many of the conservatives especially
republicans who are willing to talk
about this
and with republican lawmakers and
governors and everything it took a while
it was a lot of cajoling that went into
uh getting to the point where they were
willing to talk about this issue at all
but even when they do
most of the time they're they're framing
this all about oh i just care so much
about women's sports
i'll be perfectly honest with you i i
don't really care that much about
women's sports
for its own sake
especially if the women themselves and
the people who run these these leagues
are not willing to stand up and defend
their own sports
as far as that goes i mean you made your
bed now lie in it
if you're a female athlete
and you're gonna go and actually
participate in this charade that's on
you
i don't feel any great need to go in
there for you and do the job that you're
not willing to do that's this is it's
your sport protect it if you're a female
athlete protect your own sport
if you're not willing to do it and
female sports go away that's your fault
it's nobody else's fault
the reason i care about it
is because again it's this is an untruth
and i care about the truth a lot more
than i care about women's sports or
men's sports for that matter
or fairness you know
truth is a lot more important than
fairness i would say all right
stephen a smith over at espn has been
off of his show for a month
apparently i didn't
notice but uh he's been gone and he's
battling covid
and he's he's vaccinating i think he's
triple facts i would assume
he came back yesterday with a harrowing
story to tell and also with with the
lesson that he feels he's learned from
the experience let's watch
i had 103 degree fever every night
woke up with chills and pool of sweat
uh headaches were massive
coughing profusely
and it got to a point that right before
new year's eve i was in the hospital new
year's eve into new year's day that's
how i brought in the new year
and they told me had i not been
vaccinated
i wouldn't be here
that's how bad i was i had pneumonia in
both lungs
my liver was bad
um and it ravaged me to the point where
even now i have to monitor my volume
got to get in the gym every day walk
before you run and work your way back
because i'm still not 100 with my lungs
but i'm covered negative and all of that
stuff and i'm on the road to recover me
to recovery
yeah that's that's the lesson is uh
he's triple vaxxed
and he got covered anyway
and ended up in the hospital anyway
and was on the verge of death anyway
despite
multiple doses of a vaccine that's
supposed to protect against all this
and the lesson is thank god for the
vaccine
so that's the great thing unfold
unfalsifiable of course is the um
the argument for the vaccine because if
somebody uh
is vaccinated
and doesn't get coveted at all then we
can say well thank god for the vaccine
protect it against them against covet
and uh if they get coveted anyway then
we could say well thank god for the
vaccine they weren't hospitalized
and if they're hospitalized anyway well
then thank god for the vaccine they
weren't they didn't die
and if they die anyway then thank god
for the vaccine it was it was
less painful than it would have been
otherwise
but what exactly first of all you run
into the problem
of how do you know that
you say if you if you didn't have
vaccine you'd be dead well how do you
know that
you don't
almost
the vast majority of people who get
coveted especially this the the
current strain of it
don't die whether they're vaccinated or
not so how could you possibly know what
would have happened
in this other potential universe where
you didn't get the vaccine
but also what exactly is the this is
just a question what is the vaccine
doing for you
i mean a vaccine where you could get
three doses in a year
and
not only get the virus that it's
supposed to prevent but go to end up in
the hospital
now you can't question the efficacy of
the vaccine you can't do that
and in fact the times of israel reports
uh this week it says a study conducted
at sheba medical center indicates a
fourth shot
a fourth shot of the fizer chronovirus
vaccine
provides insufficient protection against
the omnicorn omnicorn variant of the
virus
the data appears to raise serious
questions regarding israel's current
strategy of boosting all people over the
age of 60.
so they're on four shots now
and uh it still doesn't it's
insufficient protection
so if you're not listen
if you're not willing to get
five shots of the vaccine in a year
then you're anti-science
you are we we have now reached a point
we've
we've leapfrogged over number four
and now you're not willing to get five
shots of the
of the the vaccine every single year
you are you are an anti-vaxxer
and an extremist
only an anti-vaxx anti-science extremist
would have any hesitation
about getting five shots of a vaccine
where you only need the five shots
because the first four didn't work
the first four didn't work uh
well enough let's say let me qualify
that youtube
um all right so protesters took to these
steps at the capitol yesterday to call
for uh legislation protecting voting
rights let's just play a little bit of
this footage here
you can see the um
you can see them and they're
they're singing
a little gospel him here
oh look is that a pastor with a rainbow
shaw or whatever that is
[Applause]
not going to let no filibuster turn me
around they're singing
and i'm informed by twitter that they
also
are they're on a hunger strike
which it looks like for a few of them
that might actually benefit them so it
isn't a bad idea
you got them singing and chanting for
voting rights meanwhile
they they have it they have all the
voting rights in the world
every single person there protesting
going on a hunger strike for voting
rights
they all have it someone just needs to
walk down those steps and say hey guys
good news you can all vote
wow does that mean that the voting
rights law was passed no no you've had
this right literally your whole life so
just go
you're fine go
this is how desperate people are
to
tell themselves that they're in some
sort of struggle
that they're suffering when they're not
really
desperate to be victims of course
desperate to be oppressed
uh whoopi goldberg over at the view she
says that um
that as bad as it is now with voting
rights and no one can explain what the
problem is or how anyone's being
prevented from voting she says that um
this this current phantom attack on
voting rights will only lead to even
scarier phantoms in the future
listen to this
this is part of the big plan this is
part of the big plan to control what
happens in america i believe what
happens in america
you take those voting rights away people
are going to be so angry but there'll be
nothing they can do about because we're
in charge next thing comes the women
we're going to take your rights away
just like we're taking x y and z because
there'll be nothing you can do this
country
seemingly or many people in it seemingly
want to be
manipulated oh i was going to say to
destroy it well i don't know if they
realize that it will be destructive
because listen when we talk about
anti-semitism and we talk about anne
frank and we can't teach what happens to
black people and which we you know
there's all kinds of stuff that's
suddenly starting to disappear now
that isn't it that is being sort of
called is well yeah it's just you
whining that's just you saying this is
happening to me
you gotta take away the women's voting
rights
that's what she thinks as i said i mean
there's there's
i have not advocated for taking women's
voting rights away
i haven't heard anyone advocate for that
seriously
um
as you know i am in favor of removing
voting rights from lots of people
and probably everybody on the view
but not specifically based on gender or
race just based on um how how stupid
they are and that's why you know
certainly the the bar that we would set
even if it was a fifth grade civic exam
that would exclude everybody on the view
but you know then again since she raised
the point i mean i'm not the one who
brought this up but she brought it up
about taking voting rights away from
women again i
i'm not in favor of that
but when i watch the view for even a
moment
you do start to think maybe there's an
argument like the best argument for
taking bunny rights away from women is
is actually the view so that's kind of
the irony here
but that's that's not what it's about
and as you know i'm i'm the only i'm a
voice in the wilderness crying out
nobody else is talking about removing
voting rights from anybody
that is just not that's that's
not a thing that's happening
but this is what the democrats are
focused on that's what joe biden is
focused on
joe biden who has
uh just completed
what what i think we can say without
exaggeration is the worst first year of
any president
in american history
and his approval ratings are plummeting
now they're at at last i saw was it 32
or 33
and this is what
people in this country are facing a lot
of practical problems
in their in their lives real problems
inflation is a real problem
the price of milk and bread these are
real problems that affect your everyday
life price of gasoline is a real problem
but democrats are all fighting mythical
dragons
slaying the monster that wants to take
voting rights away totally imaginary
meanwhile don lemon on his show last
night had some interesting words for you
idiots out there who think that you can
go off and uh do your own independent
research how dare you how dare you think
that you could
research things on your own and arrive
at your own conclusions
that's don lemon's job don lemon's job
is to tell you what you should know and
what conclusions you should reach as he
clearly explains here
we have to start doing things for the
greater good of society and not for
idiots who think that they can do their
own research or that they are above the
law and they can break the rules
australia
novak djokovic
australia said no no no
we're going to look at the greater good
of everyone in our society and you're
not part of that we don't
how dare you try to
any only an idiot would try to
do research
now in fact i i do agree
with some of the skepticism
um
not pertaining specifically to uh
anti-vaxxers but in generals i i i can i
can agree with some of the the
skepticism people have
when someone on the internet claims that
they've done their own research on
really any topic
because i run into this all the time
when someone says oh i've done my room
you need to do your research and you
know that 99 percent of the time the
person who claims that they've done
their own research what what do they
mean by research they mean
i looked up a couple articles on google
i read um the headline in the first
paragraph checked wikipedia and then
watched a couple youtube videos and saw
a facebook meme and um and and that's my
research and of course the whole time
that the person is doing this research
and again this this is this pertains to
like any subject at all for anybody
um
the whole time they're doing this
research they're specifically pursuing
information
that confirms what they already believed
going in
so
and that's not what research is
i mean research is a much longer process
so if you're doing one way you know
you're not doing real research into any
in today's topic is if you're not
reading any books about it because real
research usually involves reading like
actual books for one thing
and you're also going to be reading
perspectives from both sides and you're
gathering all kinds of information
it's a long kind of drawn out process
that's what research is
and
i of course realize as i think we all do
that most of the people on the internet
who say they've done their own research
have have done no actual research at all
they are they are in fact pursuing
talking points to support what they to
confirm their priors to support what
they already believed um
but
why why why is that i mean why have we
reached the point
where people
you know are just
loose in the wilds of the internet
trying to sift through and find
information
it's not the most ideal scenario
but the reason is people like don lemon
and cnn
that everyone realizes they can't trust
the
are sort of official disseminators of
information
you can't trust cnn
you can't trust what the news media says
about about anything
you especially can't trust that um
that they're giving you all the
information that you need
so there's the problem of the
information they're giving you is it
true or not
oftentimes it's not but the bigger
problem is what what are they not
telling me
and so there's there's a total breakdown
in trust
um
trust in all of our institutions
especially the institutions that are
supposed to be informing us teaching us
you can't trust academia you can't trust
the school system you can't trust the
media
and so people have
no choice but to go quote do their own
research
um a lot of people don't don't go about
that in a in an honest way and i think a
lot of people also don't really know how
to research things that's another thing
that the school system is supposed to
teach you
but isn't really interested in teaching
you that
because the school system isn't
interested in inculcating um
critical thinking skills
so that's entirely your fault don lemon
and not just you but all of the cnn and
and the media generally
all right here's a an important story
the most important story before we get
to the comment section
this is from fox news it says a
starbucks drive-through customer has
gone viral for ending a 23-car pay it
forward streak when he learned the
customer behind him had an order total
of 46 dollars
in a tick-tock video anonymous user i'm
blessed 55 documented his experience
which showed that he ordered a venti
frappuccino
and then he found out about this pay it
forward thing
and he found out that um the car behind
him had a tab of 46 dollars whereas his
was six dollars
and i i we've talked about this last
year i think then i canceled pay it
forward i canceled them and they're
still happening somehow
um
but this man this is what we need we
would talk about the need for people
take a stand have courage well this i
think is real courage to take a stand
right there and say no i'm not going to
participate in this
and as you know the the pay we call pay
it forwards actually pay it backward
because that's the that's the game like
someone decides to start
this
empty virtue signaling process and they
say oh i'm going to pay for the order of
the car behind me and then you pull up
and they say oh the car in front of you
paige paid for you yours
and at first you think well great that
was very nice of them you want to drive
away but then the cashier says would you
like to pay for the car behind you
why why would i want to do that
this is a perfect illustration of uh of
what of what virtue and charity and
generosity
has become in our country today
it's totally empty and pointless
i mean everybody in line at starbucks
they they all have expendable income
that's why they're there
these are not if you want to if you want
to give money to help the poor then
certainly go do that
why are you going to waste money paying
for the coffees in the car behind you
now absolutely the right thing to do is
accept
accept the generosity of the person
behind you cut it off and go about your
life
let's get to the comment section
[Music]
all right as you know we are now
accepting video comments as well
dailywire.com
sweet baby comments and uh we put those
in the front of the line before we get
to the the written comments now
so let's start let's just go through
these we'll start at clip nine and uh
and go through these comments here
hey matt well i generally agree with
your opinion on selfies i actually
happen to take a lot
i take them for my husband who's
deployed
and he takes them and sends them right
back to me
his own selfies
i absolutely love it i love being able
to have these pictures taken because i
have three boys under five and they are
not good at taking pictures of me
um
so the selfie
as much as i hate it on social media and
stuff and my
selfies never go on social media
they're very very helpful um
to help keep me connected with my
husband
uh sbg for life
all right
okay i i will carve out
a deployment exception for my selfie
moratorium i will do that i'm i'm a
generous man
maybe not in a forward drive-through
line but in other contexts i can be so
i'm willing to do that
but the understanding here the the
pledge that you're making
is that you will cease any and all
selfie activity once your husband
returns home and you're never gonna post
any of them online
we do that and we can we can we can work
out we can compromise
good
um okay let's go to number 10.
hi matt i just have to say that i'm very
disappointed that all bumper stickers
are canceled
i guess i'll have to rip this off so we
do have sweet baby getting bumper
stickers
which by the way if you go to
dailywire.com
shop uh you can find all the great daily
wire stores but mine's the best and you
can go there and and apparently buy
bumper stickers and i did specifically
say didn't i say this yesterday that um
that my bumper stickers
if i if i could i would criminalize
bumper stickers in general
except for mine those don't count so
absolutely go buy a bumper sticker sweet
baby game bumper sticker
and uh and get a t-shirt while you're
there and a mug and all the rest
all right let's go the next one
hi master matt it's gibberish here
pronouns are he him wall rocks
um
i just wanted to say that i think when
we're uploading our video comments we
should all be wearing a mask because
uh seeing masculist videos that might
spread the virus especially omicron with
how contagious it is
so i just wanted to put that out there
for everyone um other than that sbg for
life
uh i hope to see you soon thank you
that's a good point that's a very good
point in fact and i i apologize for not
for not encouraging that to begin with
uh and also we have to keep in mind you
got to be safe because there's a lot we
don't know as he points out with this
virus can it transmit
digitally
there are digital viruses your computer
can get a virus so it's not as
as unlikely as you may think but then
also i think
we have to keep in mind how startling
and traumatic it is for people to see
mask-less faces
in the first place these days especially
if you're ugly but really in general so
i think that's a good good suggestion
and uh let's watch one more
hey this week daddy maddie max maxine
here from sydney australia uh go by dirk
dam pronouns mate we talk about trump
derangement syndrome and i just wanted
to know what your thoughts were on the
other side of that that coin where
you've got a bunch of americans over
there that can't get over this undying
loyalty to trump
and um can't see past him to what is
clearly a better candidate in writer
santos both globally and for you guys
and so i wanted to know your thoughts on
that
also i saw your ben naked face on an old
facebook profile picture it was
disgusting please remove it immediately
sweet baby gang for life cheers maddie
see you mate
first of all i don't know what you're
talking about at the end there i was
born with a beard have you seen the
sweet baby gang logo
so i don't know what you're what you are
even referring to
um
as far as donald trump and loyalty to
donald trump i think it's it's the it's
the it's the power of branding really is
what it is uh why do people still watch
disney movies you know and disney's been
putting out nothing but
nothing but tripe for for years people
still watch it's branding um they're
loyal to the disney brand
even if disney hates their guts they're
still loyal to the disney brand and um
and so for trump
i don't think he hates
if if you're loyal to his brand i don't
think he hates your guts but but it is
it's a it's a branding thing and that's
that's trump's expertise um
that's one of the ways that he made all
his money was was by being a kind of a
marketing and branding expert
which
is a
obviously powerful and important skill
to have which is why i would really love
i mean the the best case scenario the
dream team i think
is not putting trump on a ticket with
somebody like desantis dream team is
trump as the king maker
behind the scenes
lending his branding and marketing
knowledge
and resources to somebody like desantis
that's best case scenario
okay now you've got the real like
two-headed monster type of thing and
that's that's what i would love to see
all right let's move to some of the
written comments
scott says
vosh
or vous i don't know how to pronounce it
reacted to your reaction to his reaction
to johnny walrus please react to his
reaction of your reaction
after a while it does get with these
reaction videos it does get a little bit
a little bit
well kind of it's like in inception
where we get lost in in it and um it
does feel a little bit self-serving
after a while
but
who knows i'll i'll watch his reaction
i'm sure it was quite interesting
david says matt i can proudly and
truthfully say that i've never taken a
selfie i'm truly living a vanity free
life
please feature my comment on your show
that's what someone who has no vanity
would say right
but thank you for your service in that
regard anyway
um
and kip says
matt have have loved the show for a long
time easily one of the greatest shows to
ever grace youtube by far agree however
you struck a nerve in the opening when
you mention men not having beards while
discussing masculinity i grow a beard so
hideous it makes luke bryan's beard look
this decent and as an insult to beards
everywhere please don't be a beardist i
feel triggered now spg for life
i i hear this a lot from men it's
i don't think it's it's an excuse
you're capable of growing some kind of
beard i don't um if i was real if i was
discriminatory if i was a bigot then i
would be discriminating against
other types of beards i don't
that's who you are that's that's
your true identity deep down and you
should
be proud of it
there there are no ugly beards i'll say
that there are ugly faces and a lot of
them which is one of the reasons why you
want to cover it with a beard
let's get to our daily cancellation
[Music]
today we cancel darren rovell who is i'm
told by wikipedia a sports business
analyst who previously worked for espn
somehow this line of work has enabled
him to amass an enormous social media
following two million on twitter alone
but unfortunately for him
that enormous following only meant that
there was a very large audience
watching this week when he imploded like
a dying star creating a black hole of
cringe so potent and powerful that it
threatens to annihilate anything in its
orbit it all began when somebody on
twitter called uh called rovell racist
now not that it matters but from what i
can tell the initial charge of racism
came from some random account called bob
m
with literally one follower
so bob m with one follower argued that
rovell's stance against paying college
athletes is racist because he is quote
trying to cut off the only lifeline that
some of the poor underprivileged
minority college athletes are able to
get
now the issue of paying college athletes
is contentious there are reasonable
positions to be held on either side of
it
i happen to be in favor of it only
because otherwise the corrupt ncaa gets
to keep all the money profiting to the
tune of billions while pretending that
college athletics is amateur which is a
big joke
that's my opinion you might have a
different one
your opinion is wrong if it's different
but you know it's not racist
so ravel could have simply ignored bob m
with one follower but instead he felt
the need to defend himself
sensing i guess an opening to virtue
signal rovell responded quote
calling me a racist is cute on this day
especially i have one of the largest
martin luther king jr collections in the
world and some of my closest friends are
black
now you may be wondering what a martin
luther king jr collection is exactly
i mean he's an historical figure not a
pokemon
that's just one of the questions that
arises from this tweet though he
initially didn't seem eager to explain
it he deleted the tweet almost as
quickly as he posted it but it was too
late
the internet had gotten a hold of it and
it was on its way to going viral ravel
was mocked ruthlessly and deservedly and
he was also shocker of shockers
accused of being racist for denying that
he's racist
now you might think that that darren
would now crawl away into a cave
somewhere
hide there until all this blows over
protect whatever bit of his dignity
remains
but you'd be wrong
he was not done humiliating himself so
later that day
he called into some sort of miami
hurricanes fan broadcast
and try to further defend himself
what you're about to hear is um
very real may sound like a comedy skit
or maybe a deleted scene from the office
but i assure you that this is real life
listen
to the fan base so we everybody can get
on the same page
sure i ha i have uh over
nine mlk signed items i am a humongous
fan of what he's done uh and over the
last seven years i've collected a lot of
things uh it's not only mlk it's a lot
of black history i own a rosa parks uh
signed
naacp
card so it was pretty shocking today how
i was called racist um
when when i i am a student and lover of
black history and it was it was i never
expected the reaction that i that i got
today
i'm so i'm sorry i'm sorry if people
think that a white man can't enjoy black
history
i'm sorry i'm i'm sorry i i i really am
i'm sorry if people think that a white
man uh can't uh uh love martin luther
king
but to me
that seems pretty counter-intuitive
somehow amid all of that
perhaps the funniest part to me is when
he says of martin luther king i'm a
humongous fan of what he's done which is
the kind of thing you might say about a
tight end when he goes over a thousand
receiving yards on the season and that
was very funny though maybe not as funny
as bragging
that you have a rosa parks trading card
and i'm not impressed by that anyway
because i have the frederick douglass
rookie card and a signed limited edition
harriet tubman jersey my anti-racist
credentials are far more impressive and
worth more on amazon incidentally
now as mentioned this self-defense
strategy by rovell not only led to
mockery laughter and derision all very
well warranted
but also to further charges of racism
deadspin ran an article with the
headline darren rovell is why white
america needs to leave mlk day alone
the article by karan phillips calls
ravel disgusting
a sadist and demented for what you just
heard there it was suggested that he
needs to quote take a crt class
which i'm sure he'll be more than
willing to do
um this is what he gets for showing off
his anti-racist resume
and and this is this is the lesson to
take away from this
what's wrong with what rovell said now
the popular view is that you shouldn't
try to prove you aren't racist by saying
you have black friends and that you
appreciate black history because
according to this view that only proves
all the more so that you're racist
but that's ridiculous of course i mean
in fact having black friends is
compelling evidence that you're not
racist against black people
admiring martin luther king jr is
another good piece of evidence it's
ridiculous to suggest that a man who
despises black people would nonetheless
surround himself with black people and
look up to black historical figures as
his personal heroes
so the problem with ravel's attempt to
prove he's not racist
isn't that he's incorrect but that he's
trying to prove he's not racist
he is groveling before a mob of people
who will hate him regardless he's
presenting evidence in the court of
public opinion even though the verdict
has already been decided
darren rovell might be a cringy
self-important weirdo
but there's no reason to think he's
racist
unless you're the sort of person who
thinks everybody with his skin
pigmentation is racist
i mean think about that article
it it's it's not an attack just on
darren rovell but he lumps in all white
people white america
because we're all the same
in that case there's no evidence that
will ever convince you otherwise
and your opinion is irrelevant anyway
so why should anyone try to convince you
of anything who cares what you think
these days there are only two effective
and worthwhile responses to the racism
charge
one is to simply ignore it
and this is gonna be the best course of
action ninety-five percent of the time
especially when the accusation is coming
from an anonymous account named bob with
one follower
the second option for the other five
percent
is to say to your accuser
i don't care that you think that
your opinion means nothing to me your
feelings are unimportant
i have no desire to be liked or
respected by you
that's how completely irrelevant you are
to me
good day sir
now you could put that into your own
words but that's the message
under no circumstances should you ever
make any sincere attempt
to disprove the racism charge
the category of racism is so broad
and defined in such an arbitrary and ad
hoc way that it's it's unfalsifiable it
cannot be disproven
and at any rate the people who wield
this hammer are lazy manipulative
bullies
by trying to prove anything to them
you've lowered yourself not down to
their level but below it
you're now lying prostrate on the ground
kissing their feet and begging for mercy
which you will not receive
it's pathetic it's embarrassing
also kind of hilarious sometimes as
darren rovell demonstrates which is why
today he is finally canceled
and we'll leave it there thanks for
watching thanks for listening have a
great day godspeed
[Music]
matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover our technical director is austin
stevens production manager pavel
vladowski the show is edited by robbie
dantzler our audio is mixed by mike
coromina hair and makeup is done by
cherokee heart and our production
coordinator is mckenna waters matt wall
show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2022
canada outlaws the truth a waukesha
judge bans ballot drop boxes and a
democrat senate candidate puffs the sin
spinach in a campaign ad check it out on
the michael knowles show